hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in general in book eight of his
institute's John Cassian is going to
take what we can call a zero tolerance
perspective against anger we should root
it out of our hearts all together in
fact towards the end of that chapter we
see him discussing this interesting
controversy that came up because there
were different versions slightly
different floating around of the Gospel
of Matthew where he asked and this is
the one of the chapter headings whether
we ought to admit the addition of
Without a Cause in that which is written
in the gospel whoever is angry with his
brother and he says Ah you know get rid
of that there is no good cause for
getting angry and what he means is with
other people and so he's going to
consider this question then well is
there any proper or good use or occasion
of anger a little bit earlier in the
work and his his answer is actually well
yes you know we he says that we have one
good use
ministerium one proper office you could
say for anger which happens to be
implanted in Serato within our human
nature now it's not getting angry with
inanimate things it's not to use anger
as a sort of source of energy it's not
to direct anger against our fellow human
beings our Brethren as he would call
them it's to direct that anger against
ourselves or you could say certain
features of ourself so he tells us that
this is excellently implanted within us
for which alone it is useful and
profitable for us to admit it so useful
utility there right and profitable could
also be translated as to a certain
degree healthy salubrey right something
that is good for us so we can get angry
and what is that going to be well he
tells us when we are indignant and rage
against the lustful emotions of our
heart
so indignant is indignar right it's just
sort of a transliteration here and then
rage against means to like take the
breaks off essentially against the
lustful the lascivious if we want to be
a little bit closer to the Latin uh
emotions of our heart the movements of
our heart namely the passions The Vices
the things that are getting in our way
and he says when we're vexed against the
things which we're ashamed to do or say
before other human beings have risen up
in the lurking places of our heart as we
tremble at the presence of the angels
and of God himself who pervades all
things everywhere so when we and he goes
on to talk about how we can't hide from
God when we are looking closely at
ourselves and we realize that we're
still pretty screwed up as as human
beings right then it's okay to get
indignant and to take the breaks off to
get angry with those aspects those
lacks those imperfections those bad
Tendencies within ourselves and so we
can turn a part of ourself that normally
would be itself vicious against the
other parts of ourselves that are
vicious in order to try to
deal with them to curb them and he goes
on and he talks about how this
specifically works when it comes to
anger itself and it's interesting here
because some people would say well you
can't use a particular
emotion against that very emotion now
can you and cascian would say no no you
actually can't we experience this and we
can you know conceptualize this as well
he says at any rate when we are agitated
against this very anger right
so when we are getting upset with the
fact that we're losing our temper or
we're having responses that
feel a little bit scary and out of our
control or we know our the wrong thing
to do the wrong way to interpret things
and then he talks about three
ways in which this works out so what are
we angry with
he talks about when we are moved or when
it moves us
right so that's the uh sort of plural
he's talking about we were all included
in this when we are moved in our psyche
in our soul and he uses a word for
having stolen or snuck in right the
anger has snuck in and it is against our
brother our against our fellow human
being so that is when we ought to be
getting angry at it and we couldn't get
angry at it for the very fact that it's
like tricked us it's gotten us to start
agitating against another human being
and then he also says in anger so irati
that's us and this is the kind of anger
that would be good we force out what he
calls it's deadly
incitements
instead
so you know an instigation sometimes we
call somebody an instigator when they
like to stir stuff up they're like hey
why don't you go and him fight over
there right he's saying bad stuff to you
go go kick his ass right so that's an
instigation and that's what anger does
to ourselves right and these can be in
fact deadly right uh lethales they can
lead us to not just saying bad things
but to beating people's skulls in or
throwing them off of precipices or
buildings or you know all sorts of other
things as well ruining people's careers
their reputations their potential for uh
making money to feed themselves and
their families so we get angry ourselves
at those very suggestions those very
instigations that anger is doing and we
try to force those out say I'm not gonna
go along with you and then he also talks
about not permitting that very anger to
have damaging hiding places noxious
and it's interesting because the
language here is talking about sort of
like double secrets we have secrets
within our heart or more literally our
chest pectores right and those secret
spots can be damaging hiding places
noxious deadly hiding places
unhealthy hiding places where that anger
can Fester as he talks about in other
chapters of this work so these are ways
in which we don't just turn anger
against all the vices or bad habits or
emotions but specifically anger against
anger itself and he gives some
interesting examples drawn from the life
of the as he calls it the Blessed David
who he also calls the prophet right
why because David is credited with
having written the Psalms and as having
you know done some other important
things and he says
um
to be angry in this fashion even that
the prophet teaches us who had so
completely expelled it from his own
feelings he would not retaliate even on
his enemies and those delivered by God
into his hands right now he's talking
about uh uh you know uh the Psalms and
he says when he had longed for water
from The Well of Bethlehem and had been
given it by his mighty men brought it
through the midst of the host of The
Enemy At Once poured it out on the
ground and in his anger extinguished the
delicious feeling of his desire and
poured it out to the Lord so this is not
anger against anger this is anger
against his desire to have this precious
water that required human lives per to
be put at risk he says shall I drink the
blood of the men who went forth on the
danger of their souls another example
when she may threw stones at King David
and cursed him in his hearing before
everyone and uh abhishai the captain of
the host wanted to cut off his head and
Avenge the assault of the King David
moved with Pious wrath it says against
this Dreadful suggestion of his and
keeping the due measure of humility and
a strict patience said what do I have to
do with you you sons of Zaria let him
alone that he may curse so he's not
responding in an angry way to somebody
else he's using his anger against his
own potential anger and then we see him
saying
um
uh here we go who is he that that who
shall say to dare to say why hast thou
done this behold my son who came forth
from my loin seeks my life and how much
more this son of Benjamin let him alone
it may be the Lord will look on my
affection my Affliction right so David
is providing examples of these
principles that the monk is supposed to
take to heart and then interestingly
um Cassian is going to bring up some
discussions coming from Paul's letter to
the Ephesians which have these two very
famous
um
precepts meaning things that you're
supposed to do be angry but sin not
right and let not the sun go down on
your anger
what is this supposed to mean he says
the next verse explains this very
clearly the things you say in your
hearts be sorry for them on your bed
that is whatever you think of in your
hearts when sudden and nervous
excitements Rush In on you correct and
amend this with wholesome sorrow lying
as it were on a bed of rest or moving by
the moderating influence all noise and
disturbance of Wrath and then he says
the Blessed Apostle when he made use of
the testimony of this verse and said be
angry and said not added let not the sun
go down in your wrath neither give place
to the devil so letting the sun
interpret it allegorically of
righteousness go down on your wrath if
you're angry he says we straightway give
place to the devil in our hearts then
how is it that above he charges us to be
angry saying be angry and sin nuts we
seem to have a contradiction here
and cassian's explanation which
reconciles that contradiction is he's
saying well what Paul is actually
telling you
is be angry with your own faults and
tempers and interestingly false here is
vitis so it's not just like yeah you
made a mistake it's a vice vice is right
so once again we find the bad things in
ourselves the things that need to be
rooted out we can be angry with those
because we're not sinning we're not
doing wrong to be angry with ourselves
for giving in to lost or you know anger
or greed or anything like that at
furorivestro right so and your own
temper your own exhibition of anger uh
and why he says
if you acquiesce them if you're going to
give in to these then the son of
righteousness May on account of your
anger will go down on your darkened
minds and when Christ departs you may
furnish A Place For The Devil in your
hearts the tempter the one who can't
make you do anything wrong but certainly
can you know offer you inducements right
we can go back to anger and it's
instigationes right it's incitements so
you know what Cassian is saying here is
yes there is some limited scope for
anger I mean ideally you could get by
without it but if you're going to be
angry be angry at those parts of
yourself those aspects those dimensions
of your soul that is still screwed up
and not just screwed up a little bit but
you know seriously screwed up perhaps
even your own Tendencies towards getting
angry for the wrong reasons wrong time
all the sort of things that we could
list or in general at other people at
all so there is some legitimate scope
for anger but it's pretty narrow and
it's going to be entirely directed back
on the person who is feeling that very
anger